thank you
bro you got no game
hello hi hello my name is Kirsten very
nice to meet you guys
she's definitely been in a past video
she did
she did the one where there's like a
bunch of women surrounding one guy and I
think the guy was black
oh let's go hmm you like yeah okay you
just really pay attention to these
[ __ ]
I never forget faces okay never never I
don't forget faces okay unless you got
plastic surgery then you're not the same
thing yeah that's your fault I didn't
forget you [ __ ] you changed
the person
Fair that's your fault
yeah I've gone from Kylie Jenner to
General Kelly
General Kylie
that meant nothing and everything yeah
they understood yeah yeah they
understood the knowledge has entered
your cranium
as in yes I want you to stay standing if
exit the stage one I'm not a single one
of these dudes now not a single one of
these dudes leaving
white and blonde you already know these
dudes are on it and it's not my time I'm
just saying it is what it is
like yeah
yeah guys don't get mad at me I'm just
telling you I would have stepped out
uh she's too young you have to step out
I have to step out you have if you don't
uh I'm calling the FBI yes yes
you should show up on drama alert or
something you know what I mean damn
right I'm calling it should say get his
ass we finally got him
about to keep all this money for me
hey you do that I kill you
who's gonna do the honors yeah
yeah where are you from Chris I'm from
San Diego San Diego yeah yeah
I'm from Spain hey arriba
how do you feel about uh paella I'm a
student so I'm a senior at UCSD and I
also work a lot I um but honestly I
really like working
ah shout outs my man David he's like huh
[ __ ] that's rough when we smashing never
it's like you want to date a dude you
always working I've got a whole lot this
is the truth okay every every person in
University seems to give the same speech
that's why I used to hate dating girls
who were in University when I was like
speech oh my God exams
I got a paper due on Monday oh my God uh
uh uh I gotta study all week because I
got exams I gotta [ __ ] it's August yeah
but exams are coming oh
shut the [ __ ] up like we get it we all
got bills to pay [ __ ] deal with your
[ __ ] dealing with students is the worst
you're not in med school I don't care
what are you majoring in in school
environmental science and I'm minoring
in econ what do you like to live for fun
hey I heard one word and I got and I
knew exactly
[Music]
San Diego is
no you're doing the more Cuban stuff
yeah I think you got the listen Spanish
I think so but I heard it too what do
you like to live for fun no I don't
think in Spanish how do you what what do
you like what do you think is Mexican
where is he from no Chile he's too lying
she's
no not necessarily either Chile he could
be from okay you get two guesses I got
two guesses okay go ahead you say Spain
I say Spain Argentina that's my two best
okay so I'm gonna say Chile
in central Mexico okay okay cool and you
heard what she heard is actually what
what do you like to look for fun
whatever
I like to do for fun I listen to Shakira
is that how we say that Shakira isn't
the Bad Bunny that they're listening to
now yeah everybody's on really tried to
like pick up new hobbies I find the time
because I want to find the time I don't
sit around at home I take every hour of
the day that I can to be yeah wait a
minute I'm too sober for this [ __ ] this
black guy he's like yo we're getting lit
I'm too sober for this [ __ ] yeah I'm not
going in the waters with you my girl I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm gonna let you finish
up
listen I'm probably not gonna win this
let me get some free drinks yay let me
turn up before I turn out yeah
everything
why not thank you bro just let me know
when that's perfect oh dang you just
brought me
wow thank you bro bro oh so we not
smashing bro bro
it's like a respectful bro you know what
I mean but yeah that's that's basically
my life every day I try and I go to the
gym almost every day and that's a big
big activity of mine hiding the gains
under the outfit me too me too let me
let me get awarded because all these
guys have been talking and I want to
smash and I ain't got nothing else to
say but that's the wrong things to be
saying no more me too yeah me too how
you feel about me too you want to give
me two
yeah yeah dead ass dead ass if a girl's
just in a back alley right and it's dark
and all she hears out of dogs me too me
too
she probably thinking like oh it's I'm
about to get great yeah yeah graped yeah
wait what's your my favorite artist is
black bear oh my God
you do too much bro you do too mine me
too me too mine too mine too me too
that's pick me bro there's ways to get
[ __ ] without having to be a big old
pygmy like black bear this is why girls
respond generally pretty well when
someone nags her because like if someone
just insults her just a tad bit not to
be perfectly mean but just like a light
one they're like oh this dude's not just
brown-nosing to get on my pants because
that's what it sounds like don't it yeah
oh I agree too yeah [ __ ] uh love
feminism and I think I said man I should
make half women make like yeah I agree
me too me too it's like rough chill they
can feel your desperation I have a funny
story for um like one time I was in uh
PB I was so drunk your story better be
funny it's not you wanna know why
because they stop the music
so I don't think this is going anywhere
oh they're going to uh yeah yeah let's
find out you win the Crickets yeah like
one time I was in uh PB I was so drunk I
gave I gave him like my debit card
instead of my ID
okay yeah cool but then I no but then I
I then I gave the
cue in them listen listen listen listen
listen listen listen listen listen
listen I'm gonna tell you that's my
that's my time I call it listen listen I
said cue in the Crickets listen listen
let me just say this as someone who
edits videos I could see what you were
doing Jubilee editor I want you to know
I'm watching yeah and I see you and I
understand where it's going and I
appreciate the work you put I really
thought it's like hey Jubilee anywhere I
I see you and I want you
whoa whoa no it's okay bro you can swing
that way I don't mind how do you know
it's a dude you don't think women can
hit it that's not what I said that is
what you said swing what way
the Jubilee way look look at the credits
what are you trying to say like it's a
dude how do you know have you looked at
the credits yeah no you're assuming and
that's your internal bias your internal
sexism okay yeah yeah yeah I want you to
look inside I want you to look inside I
want you to look deep in there and see
where your problem is you just wish it
was a man so anyways carry on what what
hey you guys saw this you know he has
made it be Seafood to do the wrong thing
okay yeah cool but then I no but then I
I then I gave the then I gave my ideas
but let's be honest that was a chick I
don't think you guys would have done the
same intense and I could be wrong
you guys got a little meanness in you
too but yeah sometimes I think
especially Abba and preach a lot of the
things that they say do make sense but
sometimes they just mean for no reason
and I'm mad at it I ain't mad at it
because you clapped my homies join join
the Dark Side it's fine hey hey you
already know yeah hey that's you and I
want to say put the link I want to say
put the link put the link I'm proud of
you put the link I will yeah that's what
they see in general really like someone
who's also outgoing I actually I'm very
outgoing myself and I like someone to be
even more outgoing than that so that's
like a big thing for me the virus is
high yeah
like adventurous like hey let's let's go
to this place right now let's go right
like someone's got to leave the pack and
I feel like I do that a lot myself so
it's cool to have someone else do that
for once and
I don't know in terms of like
physicality I think I just like handsome
men I think that's my type handsome men
you have nine handsome men yeah
my dude
I respect it because you're trying stop
being a pygmy
please
hey bro you got no game bro
[Music]
I want you guys to appreciate the
difference between men and women even
when Jubilee brings them up you saw the
way the women be like oh I felt like you
guys had a lot of chemistry my dude
didn't even watches it bro you got no
gay
ah
no no I appreciate it I appreciate him
[ __ ] David because it's facts yo
look at the place someone might say
that's just it's not me it's just the
truth he ain't got no game
that's not even me and actually you know
what
you know what
him saying that
might actually help to do it eventually
you know what doesn't happen dude no I
think you have great Christmas tree and
I think you guys are good and I think
this and I think that that doesn't help
nobody no but be like straightforward be
like wow you've got no game and you
think it's just this guy saying it look
at all their faces no no no they know
they're laughing they know he said oh
[ __ ] you told them and the other one
over here is like and then this one over
here is like you guys do that in the
hood all these guys you know all these
guys are thinking the same thing
they just voiced it I I just want to
just appreciate the difference in that
Kuwait Community I thank you 100 well I
was expensive for you wait who Yoo-hoo
it was going good until you did the ID
story and we were like okay who actually
felt like they like really related to
her and like really liked her and like
would want to go on to the next round
let's just make sure that like people
are in okay I do like for like for me I
just didn't feel like I like related to
her on some levels because like I'm like
like I think your music tastes yes yeah
no I I I appreciate the way these guys
are like I don't think you want me bro
so I'm gonna just walk the [ __ ] off off
the set because she said she like
outgoing people I like watching anime
jerking off the hentai I appreciate that
kind of energy but the girl because I
would do the same thing this girl tells
me even if I'm physically attracted to
her she's talking about she needs
somebody out going I'm like Brian and
all that so I meet women who are like I
want to go hiking and get I want to go
surfing and I'm like well we're not
gonna go together because we're never
going to see each other that's how I'm
thinking in my head because activities
just sound draining to me I think
they're like I'm an art student so like
I can only relate music
I think it was like too quick to like to
say like I can't relate to that person I
for sure want to know her better like
like to like continue
you know the thing about that having no
game though is that the girl might have
been into him regardless
because you know he's a tall Dude Looks
half decent she might have been into it
anyways so when they eliminated him they
said bro you ain't got no skills so I
don't know to me I would have probably
kept him in because he might have been
the type what
what that was another type what him yeah
you'd be surprised possible ladies in
the comments would the guy with the
shitty ass ID story would that have been
your type I'm asking I'm curious if you
guys would have thought he was
attractive and you know a bunch of women
would be like Miss King yeah yeah
hello what's up Kirsten how you doing
are you guys coming
no no no I don't I really don't
understand how you seem like you have
like a lot of things going on
I wish I had much more of like the drive
in me to do that like I love going back
home and just being like that I'm like
yeah so all right well you're eliminated
bro like why are you even here she said
she likes act going dudes you just out
here talking about I want to sleep in my
bed and jerk off like nobody wants you
like it's like a chill time I don't know
do you have a job uh right now no
so this is the plan of young men no job
no car
student
girl's not gonna be checking for you
[Music]
like it's why they like older dudes
generally I don't know
you know yeah get out of here I'm from
Argentina that's why
[Music]
oh
I was about to say Argentina but I
couldn't you know but it really yeah you
know yeah it was one or the other for me
yeah it was Argentina because that's
where the whitest Spanish people in
Latin America are yeah or Spain and the
reason I said Argentina instead of Spain
was my two options was because the
accident didn't sound perfectly Spanish
from Spain it sounded closer to Latin
America but he didn't look like Latin
America other than artists the list was
not there yeah I've been here for two
months so wow you say like you spend
time in the ocean so that's cool I've
been getting served here so that's I
don't know have you served here in L.A I
have not in L.A actually I don't know
how it is up here I don't I don't think
it's as great as San Diego to be honest
I think San Diego's got some killer surf
so I agree yeah and the water is clean
like super clean have you ever been to
South America I've been to Costa Rica
Costa Rica oh nice but I absolutely
loved it there it's been my favorite
place I've ever traveled I I want to go
to Costa Rica so bad like so bad they
they have the best waves over there
you feel what I'm saying girlfriend
because he's going for it I think
Santiago might win yeah I think that's
who I got my money on where am I gonna
take you out for your our first date
what do you like to eat oh wow
I really like Italian food you can't
take me on a date you ain't got no job
she said whoa wow that's forward brother
you not winning
brother I guarantee you not winning
you got you got anyways yeah carry on
you're not winning oh he got the Hassan
painted fingernails
that's a style
when you got a job
uh when you like to cosplay as a
communist
[ __ ] political nerd I don't care
about your Corrections it's kind of
interesting because I do consider myself
very adventurous but the one thing I am
not adventurous in is food like simple
foods that is what I'm eating pizza
burrito yeah I'll take a cheese pizza
cheese burrito uh-huh he's like baby
baby
that's what it was the only thing
seasoned about this girl is her tan
because outside of that I don't think
she's ever touched condiments like that
that's crazy condiments are condoms
I work at a Italian bakery and I'm like
oh I'm a baker there so I do that okay
the pizzas
okay Baker I think we got two
contestants now bake my cake and eat it
yeah we got two of them yeah I think she
thinks this guy's handsome yeah how you
feel about nightlife I mean you have
been to Europe parties in Argentina
usually like we go to the Nightclub at 2
A.M yeah and we party that until like
six and then we may go to another party
afterwards yeah we party we party hard
Argentina but here I go to the like the
venue or the place like nine am I out
I'm out in my bed like at three yeah
exactly I mean I can't imagine being out
later than two in the morning all my
Europeans like [ __ ] listen when I was
in Portugal the [ __ ] didn't open until
11 and it didn't close till six in the
morning and that's the team clubs that's
the normal regular clubs The Crazy Ones
go way later than that
way and when I say it opens at 11 [ __ ]
don't show up at 11. because that's just
when it opens [ __ ] not showing
up until one in the morning if you go
there at 11 you're gonna get there at
the same time as staff
and then she'll be like oh are you a new
worker you work here now
you're a new guy go over there at 11.
waiters yeah so they open at 11 so they
could put ice in the bucket
someone who maybe considers themselves
to be a little bit more reserved yeah I
would say I am but like once I get like
more comfortable then I'm like you're
gonna be like you're annoying like
please like leave me alone leave me
alone like I'm done with you wow that's
aggressive
make sure you don't end on something
like that no but like I'm fun too like I
like to go out I like trilingual so I
can speak three different languages
French Italian and English that's cool
so I'm really outgoing as well okay it's
sometimes hard because of the English
like to communicate around yeah but yeah
I mean I don't know I just go in
Adventures like I'm like down for a plan
whenever they say something let's go
yeah I'm going I'm 100 in yes always yes
but it's good to say no sometimes as
well
foreign
[Music]
I don't think anybody should vote for me
I have friends that are picky eaters and
that's stuff Loki makes me mad yay shout
outs to you yeah yo the guy version of
the listen Okay stop I gotta ask this
question you as a viewer I ask are we
being unfair when we're saying the guy
versions of these are generally more
um entertaining and more insightful than
the woman version you know what I'm
saying like it's just nice to hear
people be self-critical in a way that's
productive not to be like oh my God like
you know I just don't think I'm a super
cool but no just to be like I don't
think I'm gonna type like she wants
somebody who's out going she's a picky
eater I hate that [ __ ] I want to be
there I like that I like it when people
are four like that that's why I like the
girls designer girl from the last one
where she was just like I like your
shirt I like people who say that so I
don't know maybe I'm wrong what do you
guys think leave a comment below right
now and let us know do you think the guy
version of the woman version is better
and you think we're being unfair and
saying either one is better but I said
that before you like masculine energy
you guys can keep this clip one day me
and preacher gonna stop working together
you guys are going to wonder why and
we're not gonna say nothing but this
clip this is it this is the moment bro
this is the moment when having a priest
died
a little bit a little bit like like
beans and cheese take like a cool it
tastes good but like you're missing out
on a lot I feel like personally I think
Leo and Santi I was thinking but so I'm
gonna make my decision up there but I
feel like Santi was providing some like
unknown when she started talking to
Santi like her whole body posture
changed she put her leg up on the chair
she crossed her arms
I take that I've come from Argentina
I've come here and I've taken your room
[Laughter]
I'm about to take your job your job too
hey editor what do you do back there
I can't do a good Spanish accent I'm not
gonna lie I could do good Portuguese not
Spanish
you have to you have to understand me
I'm going to check your woman
you're going to love me hey I'm from
Brazil yeah do you like surf it's me I'm
going to surf inside you you're going to
breathe oxygen you in your blood
all right
you have to breathe
you the juice
watching it right now dying
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
are you ready to me and who the boys
thought was your best match sure am all
right I got three one two three
long time
yeah exactly well nice to see you behind
the curtain yeah yeah I have the feeling
pretty good pretty so my picks after the
first round were Daniel
Santiago and Leia
foreign
that's you that's you
that's you I told you the Asian guy
that's in I told you and now he's pissed
off I told you because you know what
there's some women who don't really [ __ ]
with game like that and they don't
really need it and also he was
attractive enough to overcome it so even
though you're saying corny stuff she's
just looking at his looks
you know what I mean that's you that's
that whole Justin Timberlake you could
put your your [ __ ] in the box and show
it to somebody and as long as you're
attractive it's acceptable right and
then my pick this round Santiago
[Applause]
your name was not even mentioned of
course not of course not you no job
having [ __ ]
he made sure to pose right beside her
yeah of course runner up I didn't get to
talk but do you see these guns pipes
cause bullets talk louder than words
I enjoyed this video and I just want you
guys to realize there's a bias in this
but it's not just us what do you mean
I'm just saying the dudes videos are
better for some reason yeah bro
too they do